[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits the podcast
where two friends lifelong oh gosh talk
about
life for a long time i left that word
out but i put it in later i'm link
wow and i'm really wanting you to do it
again but i'm not going to
enforce that i'm rhett
[Laughter]
uh this week at the brown my friend
lifelong man uh this week at the
roundtable of dim lighting we are
picking up on our friendship through the
years series uh this time we are talking
about the high school versions of us
uh and specifically the high school
version of our friendship because as we
were just talking about a second ago we
you know let's be honest with two
friends comma lifelong comma
yeah talk about life for a long time
uh
we end up treading through some of the
same ground like we've talked about the
way that we were engaging um
you know each of us were engaging with
our sexuality through the years in high
school we've talked about how we engage
with our spirituality and now we're kind
of homing in on how we've engaged with
each other yeah yeah and not sexually or
spiritually necessarily but just uh as
friends
and uh
so we might be revisiting some of the
same uh territory but hopefully bringing
some new perspective to it and also you
did bring some yearbooks i see
yeah i asked you to bring your books but
it was this morning it was i mean it was
seven a.m i believe you have plenty of
time to find your yearbook well i'm not
gonna i did look
i have
i have a section in my garage that is in
need of reorganization that is those
like rubbermaid boxes
and they're three deep
and two or three high and it's up on
this thing that i have to get on top of
a ladder and stan i literally have to
stand i did it this morning and i feel
i'm kind of i feel bad about this
this is like a
a six foot step ladder
and in order to get to the top box i am
standing totally on top of the ladder do
not like on the green part at the top
that you're not seeing you're not
supposed to put a foot i'm putting my
business
on that
too tied to yours
like economically we are too tied
together for you to be
teetering on top of a ladder excellent
balance for a tall person though that's
true you're you're 12 foot 7 inches
above the
above the garage floor the concrete
floor thought about asking my wife to
hold the ladder
but that would have required coming back
down the ladder going up the stairs the
top two steps of the ladder are not
steps yeah yeah i i i'm ashamed
on i'm ashamed and then and you still
came down with me i still didn't find it
here
because i think they're in the way back
can i ask you something totally
unrelated before we get into this based
on something that happened to me this
morning
i love changing subjects when you go to
the bathroom here at the office
um we're still wearing masks in here
it's the utmost protection
for everybody
in our studio
so we're still in mask mode indoors
as people are working when you go to the
bathroom i'll take my mask off is that
what you're about to ask me and do you
take your mask off
no
when you if you poop
in the bathroom do you take your mask
off
i mean yes or no
no
why would i
so i could smell it more well that's one
of the benefits of
i've actually i hate wearing a mask i've
established this with my beard i hate it
i have to comb the beard out
but uh when i go to the bathroom i
actually think to myself
this is like one scenario where it
really because even when you're thinking
about a virus it does it's not tangible
and sometimes you're like i might just
really do anything but when i'm in the
bathroom and i'm pooping
i'm like this mask is doing things for
me
and also doing things for me tonight not
have to think about who was in here
before me and what particles they left
in here
if what i'm about to tell you changes
your mind
proceed with caution
uh
i have no idea where this is going but
it must be that you don't wear a mask in
the bathroom
uh
yeah i
well i don't i don't like to wear a mask
in the bathroom when i'm pooping because
you poop through your mouth i don't
yeah
boy that's hilarious
no
i don't poop through my mouth you a jerk
okay well you jerk it was a joke you
didn't but i do believe that actually is
a thing that can happen poop through the
mouth i don't want to talk about that
it's probably on webmd
i take my mask off when i'm pooping in
the bathroom because i don't want to
suck in
i don't want all this poop stuff to get
caught in my mask then for the rest of
the day i'm slowly breathing in
poopy particles you're not breathing in
it's on the outside of the mask
it's in the mask and then it's some of
it gets through the mask yeah wha where
have you read this
what research it anywhere but that's
what i do okay i'm almost sure the poop
doesn't make it doesn't seem like i'm
changing your mind but yeah so you'd
rather happen to mr open-minded rhett so
you well i mean just be open-minded
until i'm done with my story okay i'm
close-minded about things i'm right
about no no can you can you keep your
mind open until i'm done with my story
okay there's more okay i haven't even
told it yet okay all right i'm ready for
more
so i sat down to poop this morning in
the bathroom
uh i sit down and then i look over and i
make sure the door is locked and then i
realize
you know what i still have my mask on i
forgot to take my mask off and here i am
pooping
and i don't want all these poop
particles caught in my mask i want my
mask to be i'm one of those people who
like yeah takes his mask off to sneeze
because i don't want sneeze particles
inside of my mask you set the mask
outside
the bathroom
well exactly so what what i normally do
is i put my mask in my back pocket when
i'm when i'm taking my mask off for
stuff like when we're filming stuff so
what i did was i took my mask off and
then i instinctively started putting in
my back pocket and i almost wiped my ass
with my mask yeah this is appropriate
this is how ill-advised your whole
scenario is
i know i
i never would have told you that yeah i
am on the brink
of wiping my own ass
with my mask
this has happened with hundreds if not
thousands of people that makes me feel
better
because think about it oh when you run
out of toilet paper how many people have
run out of toilet paper and up until
this point in time most of us didn't
have eye masks now you've got an ass
mask and people are like well
i'm going to go into the bathroom with a
mask and come out without one have to
explain this why i mean there was tp in
there but let me tell you i came a lot
closer than i than i want to admit
do you still have this mask yes in my
back pocket so how close did it get to
your butthole what i don't know
just can you just tell just sniff it but
see here's the snapping man here's the
problem
didn't you watch that uh i love how you
didn't even want to say no you just just
snip i'm not going to say it
mike rowe had this
micro i'm going to do some podcasts they
do this if you notice that they like
just sit here with the the microphone
like this i'm going to start doing it i
didn't actually wipe my ass with my mask
um
that's why i'm still using it
and it's fresher would you like me to
tell me tell you or i can also tell me
because i'm here uh why your plan is
wrong
nope that's not what this is about i
think i think well then
if you don't think that it's obvious
then uh it doesn't need to be explained
well i think maybe i think it's more
important i always wipe my ass with a
mask it's obvious why it was a bad it
was a bad idea uh but i don't need you
to tell me you this is a violation of
our of our work protocol i mean as
you're as the co-owner of our company oh
i didn't want to discuss company policy
in this scenario but i will say that
uh the
the there's a there's a vent
yeah but
in the bathroom
when you've got your pants down you're
breathing hard
this is and you're an enclosed space
that someone else is about to come into
this is probably like one of the top
spaces that you should keep your mask on
and you're taking your mask off and
almost wiping your ass with it not
anymore man you're like you're not
anymore you own half of this company
i'll tell you man maybe we need to
adjust the process
it's so fresh to me you know it's like i
don't know
i haven't quite got the hang of this
whole mask thing yet
i think i think it's picking up steam
though people wearing masks the only way
that your plan would make sense is if
before just from a like a personal
hygiene standpoint not from a company
policy because we've already established
that you violated that
um i don't have cov
you're selling such an idiot
no i've taken two tests yeah you're
ready yeah
i understand that but the only way that
your plan makes sense
is if you were to take
my ass let me finish i didn't sound like
an idiot i just don't like it when you
tell me i sound like an idiot when it's
obvious i sound like an idiot well i'm
just hel this is where the
obvious this is for the folks at home if
he's not gonna listen to me the only way
this makes sense is to take your mask
put it in your back pocket before you go
into the bathroom which by the way
would be a violation of company policy
and if you do it outside everyone would
see you do it so be setting not only
that would be setting a bad example
then you go into the bathroom
do your business and then come out
that's the only way to follow your logic
which is to not get poop on your mask
yeah
but you're the guy who's trying to wipe
his ass with this mask so apparently
poop on the mask is not something that
you not having poop on the mask it's not
something you value
it's a very ironic what happened
obviously what should happen is
after i'm done pooping without ever
taking my mask off
i should then put on a fresh mask as i
exit the restroom that's what i'm gonna
do from now on everybody's happy
yeah you figured it out
we didn't even need to have this
discussion
let's promote our podcast well you know
we actually have a mythical pods tick
tock account because we have found that
you know sometimes things are said on
this podcast and the other three
podcasts that we have a hot dog as a
sandwich best friend's back all right
and trevor talks too much
all the mythical pods things are said
that are interesting and you might be
wanting just to get a little uh tidbit
of a podcast that works really well on
tick tock it's a little
just a little dingleberry if you want a
dingleberry of a podcast
uh any of our mythical podcasts follow
the at
mythical pods tick tock channel and if
you're just not on tick tock because
you've you know
you're you're like i just one more
platform i don't want to get on well get
over that we'll see you soon get over
that we'll see i mean i'm just telling
you this is your sign you know how when
people say that this is your sign
get on tick tock my recommendation today
is going to be tick tock so over the
course of listening the rest of this
podcast
i'm gonna recommend a uh tick tock
account and you'll be ready it'll be one
of the first ones you can follow and
i'll add to that
um so now we're just promoting tick tock
well unfortunately i i don't remember
the guy's name but there was a guy who
made a youtube video
and i i think you can you can look this
up it didn't have very many views when i
watched it like literally like three
because he had added me on twitter and
that's why i saw it
but the name of the video on youtube is
rhett and link art holes and i watched
it and it was a funny video where he's
actually a big fan who's been watching
since the beginning and has just
discovered
that we have a tick tock and that we've
been doing all these like old school
sketch stuff like the old school writing
cause he didn't know about it i i mean i
kind of i don't know with exactly the
logic but i think that was just more of
a clickbait thing okay um
this is no longer the ad by the way
we're back into the show because we're
not from you know we're just telling you
to to to follow mythical pods on
tick-tock and we're telling you to just
get tick-tock if you're saying it's not
for you because i'm going to recommend
something at the end all right
and we're told apparently but in a good
way
look at this photo rhett look at these
look at these photos of us from high
school look at that one
describe it um
this is your bathroom
at your house uh we are using a flash
camera because that's covering up your
face almost completely the flash
you're in your letter jacket
yep uh and we are both
i was a star soccer player in high
school we were both wearing
beanies which we would have called
toboggans toboggans toboggans well i
didn't say toboggan i said toboggan you
know that's because i was born and
raised in north carolina i moved to
north carolina moved around
uh and they still have the price tags on
them what does it say on there i don't
know i can't figure that out but we
we bought these toboggans and
we like to take pictures of ourselves
i took one of you
that's a cool jacket very warm
and then you took you took one of me i
don't know that's a flattering face
and again we didn't take these pictures
and then immediately look at them we
took these pictures and then waited
maybe months before we could see him
again because he had to finish the roll
and then get it developed we could we
could have invented instagram back then
doing pictures like this look at this i
mean look at how much fun we had you and
me got it
is that an index
on that's a napkin with your with your
tongue being pressed through it to make
a hole i'm taking a very point blank
close-up picture of you and then outside
of the focus range of the camera you
thought it was such a good idea that
then you took a picture of me doing the
same thing and then here's one that's
that's uh
it's tough to take a selfie
when you're uh
you know when you can't when you can't
take a whole bunch of them so we were
having a good time now this is we were
we were such good friends this is senior
year
because you've got that jacket no no i
got the jacket after my freshman year
let i got my letter jacket as a freshman
are you a hundred percent sure of this
yeah because there was no jv soccer team
everybody was on the varsity soccer team
so i like they let you get it as a
freshman
i was on the varsity soccer team every
varsity player got a letter jacket
well yeah jealous
no
did you get it as a freshman yes because
it feels like a little bit of a cheat
code it did i didn't
i i got it just
being honest with you i played in one
game a game that we won nine to zero i
know this because in the yearbook my mom
kept the um
she kept the schedule and she wrote down
the score and we were
we were in the final four of st of uh
state playoffs that year
that was the peak of soccer yeah
but i but i got my uh
i got my letter jacket and i think that
that's what i remember about starting
high school and it really had an impact
on our
friendship because
you know we were so nervous we thought a
lot about beginning high school we were
really in that head space when we were
writing the lost causes of bleak creek
because we we put our experiences into
into that story and there's so much
expectation
but i actually
started playing soccer we had um
practice like six weeks before
classes began
and i remember being so nervous because
it's like okay i'm on the soccer team
there's no try out everybody makes it
like i said but still i was nervous
because
okay you got these upperclassmen like
all of a sudden i'm playing soccer with
seniors and juniors and i don't know
that many people from bowie's creek who
are going over here and playing soccer
you played soccer in middle school
because
everybody who liked soccer kind of
played but then in high school you
started to
just
matriculate so to speak
so
soccer for me was my introduction to
high school and you didn't have any part
of that
and then that became
a part of my identity as a freshman
as a soccer player i will say that back
about season hasn't started i will say
if you don't remember this is that coach
randall is that his name
randall
uh actively almost to the point of
harassment recruited me to be on the
soccer team as the goalie yes because
you were you could stretch out well
because i allowed one goal in middle
school
one goal i was trained by you remember
peter uh what was his name he was this
famous campbell goalie that i think is
in like the campbell hall of fame for
being a goalie peter or something
and my dad hired him to come and train
me oh wow and i remember being out in
the cold
and having to learn how to do that thing
when you fall on your side and then my
dad got me like the equipment lay out
yeah i got really good i could do the
drop kick you know and i'm like six
i was already six like five going into
school he would actively
like aggressively kind of like try to
bully me into being on the the goalie
almost worked he had an abrasive
personality uh i should have done it man
the stories we could have had coach
brando was the coolest guy but yeah you
should have done it man because well i
mean you were focused on basketball with
that i gotta get ready for basketball
season and um
man but yeah chad chad hawley was a
senior and he was a really good keeper
he was great he was a great keeper he
played um
and again that's one of the reasons why
we went to like the final four
we had a pretty pretty good team but he
was a great keeper and um yeah he played
in college
but
you would have been groomed sophomore
year you would have taken over who ended
up i know brian coleman did was a goalie
for a while no no he was he was defense
yeah he was a sweeper i moved it really
really far
he could do that thing where he would
where you're throwing him from the
sideline and he would you would get a
running start and he would put the ball
on the ground do a flip and then throw
it in yeah yeah yeah and everybody would
just be like flabbergasted on the other
team and so they would just stop playing
yeah it was a great technique who was
your goalie uh
philip hatcher became the goalie
remember him yeah and he was good he was
a glutton for punishment and you kind of
have to be fearless right yeah throwing
yourself i think i was a little bit too
scared of like getting hurt also you got
to throw your body around i don't like
getting hurt so
of course i mean we were best friends
going into freshman year but like
i had this like reconnaissance thing you
were on the cross country team though
and you guys started running before not
freshman year oh you weren't
my freshman year so once classes started
i felt like
i'm wearing my letter jacket i'm a part
of something i'm i'm getting in where i
fit in kind of thing i'm part of a team
it actually helped kind of kick start
things a little bit well my brother was
a senior that helped you um
and he was like a popular guy it was you
know one of the stars on the basketball
team
um and so there was this sort of a
little bit of a one a runway set up for
coming in as another mclaughlin right
um
and
i don't know
i've never especially at that point in
my life
i've never been one to like get too
nervous about the next stage i get much
more excited about the next stage right
and so
uh i remember going there was a
before school started
that year there was a athlete some sort
of like athlete
i can't remember what it was but it was
at it was the first event at harness
central before school started
it was an orgy outside
uh
in in the tobacco pit where everybody
smoked
no it was just some sort of get together
and my brother was going and i was gonna
go with him and i just remember thinking
a lot about what i was gonna wear and i
wore these shorts and of course i tucked
a polo shirt into them braided belt had
a braided belt there oh yeah went uh
boy it got close to the knee it got
close to that tied into that knot and
send it south and no shoes i mean no
socks and uh loafers penny loafers with
no socks
wow
um but you blended in with that except
being very slinky so tan you know that
like we sunscreen we didn't understand
that that was believing it didn't we
didn't think that was a thing that you
could do
um it was like you don't need sunscreen
unless you have red hair and i don't
have red hair when you get a tan
that becomes your sunscreen is what we
can by the end of the summer boy you
were tan you know and you show up
i just remember walking into that
setting with just so much confidence oh
you had confidence well i mean you know
going in i didn't have cops going in as
a freshman six five you know you're
you're looking down on everybody you got
a brother who's already paved the way
you know a lot of people who are gonna
be there you know what i'm saying you're
good you're not going you're bringing
everyone from your school because we
were going bowie's creek joined
lillington and andrew all together and
lafayette all right so that's still the
minority and that's how i looked at it
you know it's like we've got a we've got
a faction right now where at least a
quarter of the school quarter of the
population is a minority right yeah yeah
that was enough though
but i mean yeah it was like and then all
these upperclassmen from all these other
places too you didn't you didn't know
them you really didn't know a lot of the
older
bowie's creek people too so
i mean it was definitely an exciting
time i remember like there was a there
was no commons area
in
our elementary slash middle school you
know where there was that break and
everybody would like
like
hum haul around and fiddle fart around
after homeroom after homeroom
so
me being on the soccer team
you
you were focused on basketball and then
the basketball season started
i don't know after a couple of months i
guess i mean that was october that was a
that was a big separation for us that
started to you know we had identities
apart from one another in ways that kind
of like
could get a little cliquish right
um so and i think that was the first
time we experienced that
as friends but what we discussed before
from middle school was more it was more
like well you lived on that side of town
so you had your friends and i was on the
other side of town alone now it was more
of okay i've got my soccer team
i've got some friends there i made you
know i made friends with jason
from anger
and like he would invite me to his house
and i was like okay i'm hanging out with
other people
so our horizons were expanding
and our friend group hadn't yet
coalesced
beyond what what it would become in like
sophomore junior
year
we started to develop like a
a friend group with some lilington
people some andrew people and a lot of
bowie's creek people and we had a pretty
tight group there for a couple of years
but i remember freshman year it was it
was kind of this
branching out
i didn't really
i didn't
that is true but i didn't see it that
way
it's yeah it's not something we ever
talked about because i i think more in
retrospect i definitely had this again
you know we talked about it uh
that summer between eighth and ninth
grade
and
you know going and swimming in the river
and this is when we had
at that point definitely our friendship
with ben had
really transformed and so that summer
going to the river
was something that was pretty much me
and you
uh there we still hung out with ben when
he was like when he felt up to it but
that he didn't there was a lot of times
when he didn't feel up to it and
and making that phone call and seeing if
he was feeling okay
it just created this thing that me and
you became this unit and so yeah
we talked about what we were going to
experience what we were going to do and
of course i was talking a lot about
all the women that were going to be um
here at this place but there's a
thousand people you know we're going to
this place that's got that many more
women
and i saw us as this like unit that i
kind of just took that for granted that
like okay well
i'm not going to try to find another
best friend or anything you know it's
like and i never i did i i know i was
never threatened i didn't think there
was anything that was all gonna fall
apart at this point yeah we were i mean
we were getting
we were definitely getting closer than
ever but it was the first time that we
had aspects of our high school identity
that were completely separate like you
as a basketball player right
yeah i mean there was a little bit of
that in in middle school but it it began
to
develop more but i was friends with
everybody on the basketball team like in
high school i wasn't friends with
anybody on the basketball team that's
true because you know because it's all
all new new students and there's a lot
more of them so you know the ones that
you're kind of hanging out with
yeah i mean the thing
i started to experience this
i now i kind of understand it as the
chameleon-like quality of an enneagram
three
that i never really understood was a
thing until sort of looking like a
personality evaluations but that's a
tendency to
sort of infiltrate a particular group
and be a version of yourself in that
group in order to excel in that group
and so there was sort of the basketball
version of me right
which is a totally different set of
friends because they're all on the
basketball team and kind of a different
way of being
like that version of rhett was
pretty serious and like committed and
worried about being good at basketball
and like kind of thought he was pretty
cool because it wasn't a silly
environment did you have locker room
slang
um
i don't
remember that but i'm maybe
you were like boy i'm
i'm i'm flaming some hoops tonight but
you know how you get into a certain
environment
uh
where and the basketball team
is different than the soccer team right
because the basketball team is way
smaller than the soccer team or way
smaller than the football team there's
this sense that you're like hey we're
the 12 guys
that they chose for this right there's
just this sense that like you're kind of
in this
elite group of guys and guys
especially sort of like
embrace that and kind of start to feel
like this cool gang
you would wear your uniform to
class on the day you know you wore a
suit
oh that's right you wear a suit you had
to wear a suit and tie that was the rule
you had to wear a suit and tie on game
oh wow
yeah
that's that's wild yeah and so well and
that was really once we were on varsity
which was starting for me started
sophomore year oh okay but
the point i'm making is that there's
this like mode there's a sort of a
social code amongst the basketball team
where i'm behaving in a different way
and as soon as i'm outside of that
environment i'm not that guy anymore i'm
silly class clown
rhett you know which is what i was most
of the time and then of course with you
like we were like it was a whole
different level of taking silliness
taking selfies with
being i guess i want to emphasize
the embarrassing level of silliness that
we were still i mean we've never really
stopped
but
yeah
it was just it was so so stupid we acted
so stupid it was it was fun man yeah i
mean when i read through
once i started looking at these
yearbooks and i started reading
everybody's
notes
that was it it helped put things back in
perspective first of all we went to
trinidad after our freshman year of high
school on that mission trip
because
all of our uh friends all of our church
friends were talking about we were going
and like you know the school year it
ended and this is like the big thing
we're like going to trinidad so that's
when that happened but every single
person
called me crazy
like i was i was
i guess i was i'm pleasantly surprised
and i'm sure the same goes for you
because
people would write about me and people
would write about us
and then our closest friends like
michael and trent
they would write about me and you you
know it's like we were these
uh
ring leaders amongst a group of guy
friends because we had these we were
super silly we were super crazy
um all the girls just thought we like
had
in i'm projecting my notes onto you
because i know it's true of you too
because i just read these it's like all
the girls just thought and our friend
group just thought we were just
crazy thank you for making us laugh all
the time that type of thing
and then there were people who were not
in our friend group who were on the edge
who would say a little bit differently
like
you are the craziest person i've ever
met i don't i have no clue you know it's
like we were
we were just and it was a silliness it
wasn't like
it it wasn't like jackass like johnny
knoxville like they'll
we would do some
some
daring things but it really was more
about just cutting the fool like
being the butt of the joke if i had to
be
that type of thing
class clowns and it and us being a unit
that would bring other people into it
like people our friend group the way
that i
can see in the yearbook is that they all
fed off of our energy and it's just
something sometimes i feel like we've
developed
personas because we have
it was nice to go back and like
have like a 98
uh
agreement amongst notes that like we
were that way then too
we were organizing
we've always been about entertaining
people and so if you think about the
things that we ended up doing there was
this
all right we've got this group of people
let's figure out like let's
find a way to do something that's a fun
experience so something as stupid as
let's do that thing where we
uh in the middle of the summer we're
gonna go to the movies but on the way to
the movies at waverly place yeah we're
going to turn the heat on you know we're
in this is north carolina it's 95
degrees at night 90 humidity let's turn
the heat all the way up and play heavy
metal music really loud and thrash and
thrash all the way to kerry and then
when you see how much you can and then
when you get out of the car it'll it'll
it'll it'll feel great it'll be cool
you'll be sweating your ass off though
and then you gotta you'll stink in a
theater let's get our friends to do that
with as long as we all stink together
bring more people and i've and we both
like that love to bring people into that
situation so i think that this career
that we found ourselves in just
bringing people along for a good time
there's a lot of notes after in freshman
year notes
about
hey this summer
can i
maybe i can go chase cows with you guys
because that's what we had been doing
for
a couple of years like everybody knew
that after school
we would go back you know we your
brother would bring you home
kevin would take me home and then we
would get on our bikes as freshmen we
would we were still doing that middle
school type stuff where it was like
we're going into the woods
we're going swimming in the river we're
going to chase these cows and then we're
going to come back the next day and
we're going to tell everybody about it
and as if they missed the best thing
ever it's like so by the end of the year
people were like can i can i come
can i maybe maybe i can do that we did
the camping was later that was like we
did eventually bring them along yeah we
told that story about they all ended up
crying
yeah so several of them did
when they almost drowned in the river
and it was that was a bad move so there
was the yeah but back to your basketball
identity thing and my soccer i did
anything yeah we were starting to branch
out but at the same time
those things like chasing cows
and spending like the default being
if it w if it was
when we weren't practicing like when i
had soccer practice every day after
school when that was over then it was
basketball but then we would always find
time even when like the reason why
we would chase cows during basketball
game days is because you weren't
practicing after school i think and so
it was our only opportunity to still get
out there and get back into the woods it
was kind of like those guys those people
who love to fish and they're all they
carry around the fishing pole and
they're always waiting
like i see a water hole i'm gonna go
over there and fish
we were kind of that way about getting
back into the woods
in sophomore year you got your license
we could do that even more it was close
to junior year i guess with the summer
after that i got my license but right
that overwrote like that time in the
woods chasing the cows
the fact that we
were unabashedly
best friends doing strange things
i think
i mean that was the backbone of our
friendship and there was this identity
of okay there's the two of us are you in
on it or not and i think that that's
what um
that's what sort of
solidified our friendship and solidified
us as a unit
uh is the fact that okay
if we've got this if one of us has this
ridiculous idea to do something
it's you know there's no question where
the other guy's gonna go along with it
right okay i know i'm into this now
let's go and try to get other people on
board but but we're bringing this thing
to to our friends like even with the
the idea to start the band
well yeah it's like okay
eric gets a guitar and starts playing it
and it's like his intention in getting
in the guitar is is more like i i i want
to learn how to play the guitar maybe
get girls it's like this is something
that i'm interested in doing just
personally it's a hobby that i want to
explore
and then we're immediately thinking well
yeah but we need to start a band
you know it's like it's you've got a
guitar
we are all friends that means we should
start a band that just seemed like the
logical next thing it's like how do you
blow this idea the seat of this idea out
into something that is this big
experience and
me and you didn't there there wasn't
this like stopping to convince each
other it was like all right yeah banned
great idea
now let's convince some other people
about this
yeah that was the kind of mode and i
think that
getting doing that without ever having
to confer about it
is
it's the reason that we ended up working
together
and yeah because people are always like
we forget two is a majority with any
idea but people forget
we forget the sort of novelty
of the the depth and length of our
friendship but also the fact that oh
you've been working together for all
this time and like how does that work
and how do i
explain that to me and it's like well
because there were the there was a
unwritten language that was being
developed and honed over many many years
where there's a whole lot of other
things that
normal business partners
have to have a conversation about
something they have to work through
something they have to get on the same
page about something i'm not saying
we're always on the same page we're very
different in some ways and we work
through things we have a lot of conflict
we've talked about that in the past but
the core of it is something that there's
a lot of unspoken things and i think
that high school
as we sort of
broke off from the trio of of the two of
us and ben just because of what was
happening circumstantially with ben
began to that that began to solidify i
remember freshman year english class
kelly smith she dr our teacher she drove
a mitsubishi 3000 gt
and she
we're in the same class boy we gave her
we gave her hell but she loved us
because she thought we were ridiculous
we were and we were kind of a just a cut
up duo but we were very engaged with
what she was doing she was super cool
we're gonna do you're gonna do a speech
and we're like well okay wait
what we're about to break out for the
speech
very participatory in class
we
had a section on film
she taught us the rule of thirds she
taught us
you know uh
lots of cinematic principles and then
said all right guys
you're going to divide up
i think it was two groups it might have
been three but i maybe just two
and you're going to make a movie like
who here has a video camera
and you're like i got a video camera and
trent was like i got a video camera and
was like okay so you guys are on
different different groups and then she
assigned the groups i got assigned to
trent's group not your group and i was
really pissed off about that because i
was like
we've already we've been what a missed
opportunity we were making videos in
middle school we could be showing this
we could be cut into a video right now
so much further along in our careers if
she had let us work together in that
class so i was pretty bummed out i don't
know what your group made but my group
made a a horror movie like a la scream
involving um
let's see a car like somebody calling
from
calling a house but then realizing they
were calling from inside the house
because
wasn't there a thing where you could
call
your own number and make it ring yeah
can you still do that
i don't know i don't have a landline
you could call and make you
and something about that was like
pivotal in the script of like oh my god
he's in the house
that sounds interesting and compelling i
have no idea what my group did i think i
was more of a cinematographer i wasn't
as much into it because it wasn't a
comedy and what you and i weren't making
it together and i but i do remember it
being a lot better than your groups so i
did feel a little vindication are you
serious like you maybe i was like maybe
he needs me more than i need him all
right all right you're rewriting history
i i don't remember yours being better
though well i don't remember what i did
but i'm sure it was memorable i'm sure
it was a comedy because i used every
opportunity that i had to and i'm sure
you took took charge yeah because
somebody has to i don't remember the
camera
but yeah i mean that was pivotal like
that was a that was a great class and it
was like we actually started to
that was the first time we started
thinking about oh there's principles
associated with filmmaking
you know because you watch movies you
know it didn't register with us so
a question i want to explore but i know
we're going to read some from the
yearbook so i don't know which one we
should do first because i want to talk
about the
just the aspect of like future planning
stuff
well that dynamic hour
let's see
1995. so this is
1993.
okay
this will play right into what you want
to talk about first of all after
freshman year
i'm pretty sure
we've read this one before
like your note to me
link neal you have 14 different things
going for you well hold on you didn't
read the uh
i wrote something in charles lincoln
smith johnson neil iii
okay
okay
you so you i was embellishing i was
making fun of how many names you had
yeah
you have 14 different things going for
you oh i think you're very complimentary
but i can only mention one you have soul
when i say soul i'm not talking about
the kind of soul that veronica swann
said you had i don't remember her saying
i had soul at all or what kind it was so
i can't comment on that
but i'm talking about the kind that run
dmc
dmc or
dmc you just spelled it three different
ways talks about i think you thought
that was funny like i would like i i
like i what did it do like it was
alternate spellings of dm's oh and then
like some like phonetic spellings
genetic yeah
if you got the soul then keep the soul
if you ain't got the soul then get the
soul
fart blossoms only come once a year
so don't let them pass by you
if you try hard you can catch one in a
net
if you don't catch one
then buy one i'm sure your granddad has
plenty um my granddad clyde my papa he
would he would always call me blossom
right
and you signed it rico
and then in parentheses you put stupid
so self-deprecating p.s
i wanted to do something that would mess
up your yearbook so look down and then
in the big scrawl you wrote rusty
jernigan
which was another guy we went to school
with yeah
so i signed as another person very big
and obnoxiously there was nothing
meaningful in that there was nothing
heartfelt oh come on there's a lot of
heartfelt stuff in that i mean think
you've got to read between the lines i i
really want you to dig up
what i wrote in your yearbook and i'm
sure it was equally stupid
hold on but i mean
yeah i'm trying to sweet i'm trying to
crack you up but read between the lines
man there's there was a connection there
what what
okay that's like 14 different things you
got going for you yeah
you've got soul that's the best
compliment you got in the whole yearbook
probably
yeah
i still don't know what you meant by it
though i don't either it's been a while
and then the fart blossoms part i have
that's just that's just silliness just
pros
that's just pros it didn't rhyme
uh let's see coming of age 1995. so this
is i didn't sophomore year i think they
gave us our yearbooks
graphic design on this well the graphic
design on this looks like a three rail
spill horrible
it's like it's like somebody discovered
fonts for the first time it's like well
let's use all three all of them yeah
not all there
that's what we were was this on the back
not all there
but here's here's the best
what does that mean i mean there's a we
weren't on the yearbook committee
so we can't take credit for that
non-sequitur not all there but here's
the best
uh
coming of age this is a slightly better
one yeah this is tasteful design wise
yeah i wrote on the inside cover link
neal
will never come of age
that is hilarious that's that's true
[Music]
you wrote
lunar
you've never called me lunar
cute little nickname that uh starts with
an l but you've never called me that
before or since it was just for this at
your book like the uber was an
opportunity for just
to work out new material well i was
hoping you would come of age and start
using it as your moniker
but this gets to kind of your point of
ambition
lunar coming soon to a theater near you
the judge
the script is to be written
the life is to be lived
the day is to come and we will be there
you will be there i will be there
let's get there wow rhett you signed it
rhett wow
do you know what the judge is
i don't know man it's a movie it's
awesome though it's a movie idea
that
i think you just made up on the spot for
the sake of
saying i didn't expound on it
um
the scriptures would be written the life
is to be the life is to be lived yeah
we're going to write a script and then
live it
the day is to come
i think is we're going to write a script
and we're going to live the life of
making the movie well so
we will be there you will be there i
will be there let's get there now this
is this is what i wanted to talk to you
about
i love this because there's a you know
there's a scene in the lost causes of
bleak creek
uh and you may have figured out that rex
and leaf are you know analogues to rhett
and link
and um
yeah i did there's a there's a scene in
[Music]
in the book where
rex is like
getting leaf to think about uh something
in the future and something that they're
going to do i think that how they're
going to meet uh they're going to have
breakfast with uh
robert zumachus yep
and
that was in the book because it was very
indicative of the very
big dreams
that i would
like bring into our friendship and be
like
come on man we're going to do something
amazing and
and this is what and this is the plan
we're gonna go in one point it was we're
gonna go to unc asheville
i'm gonna play basketball there because
they've come to see me play and they've
written me some letters and so they you
know they're kind of recruiting me
junior year
and they have a film school or a film
minor i couldn't remember which one it
was and so hey
we'll go to unc asheville
i'll play basketball we'll major in film
and then we'll become
filmmakers
yeah and so the the thing i i was like
do they have a soccer program so no i
didn't so i did not care about soccer i
never again i never it
the way that i thought i just knew that
you were always going to be into the to
the idea right and so
it wasn't like i ever was like all right
i got to have this conversation with
link it was more just like
it went without saying that if i said
this kind of thing in your yearbook even
though i'm kind of just screwing around
but like i'm you know i'm like
we were having these disgusting
intention about like the future in the
cow pasture like the the discussions
that led to the blood oath which may i
i believe like i don't know when we've
dated the blood over this had to be
around the same time but i have to i
if i had to put money on it i think that
the blood oath is around
after sophomore year sometime in junior
year that's when you're getting like
that's when you're formulating this unc
asheville plan
um you're like we're thinking about our
you're thinking about your future your
parents thinking about your future
uh
the counselors are telling us to apply
to places that would have been between
junior and senior year because i
wouldn't have been getting any interest
i got interested uh
that's late to do uh the blood oath was
earlier what i'm saying is that i'm just
saying the unc asheville idea because i
played aau basketball
and had had a pretty good junior year
and so i was i wasn't getting college
letters after sophomore year okay so
that that was when it was the blood oath
could have been that late then it could
have been maybe
junior late junior year or summer after
junior year is that when you did aau
summer after
or during june i did summer after
sophomore and summer after junior okay
so in the in that realm so we were
having this conversation so then yeah
there wasn't the judge is not a specific
idea we had no but you made it very
specific in the yearbook because that
was just a choice you made but it was a
reflection of
converse like
deep bloodletting conversations that we
were having in that cow pasture we never
stopped going to the cow pasture
throughout high school we went back too
we did not outgrow that
um again if you want us good mythical
morning we go back to bowie's creek um
and we did a three or four episode
series where we literally take you to
the places that we're talking about so
check that out um
but yeah i mean
you
articu i mean you orchestrated in your
mind this this unc asheville plan it was
a compromise
to like
uh you know
with your with your dad thinking about
okay he's he's given you so much
opportunity and you've capitalized on it
when it comes to basketball well this
pays that off
but it also gets you into a film program
and which is something that we wanted to
do
and then how did i respond to that i
mean you said you knew i would be on
board i mean i think that's that's a
dramatic understatement because for me
i
you know i did i didn't know how to
engage in the future i didn't know how
to make plans i wasn't you know
my mom wasn't having conversations with
me about like hey you can take this
thing you're interested in and turn it
into the rest of your life like you were
having those basketball conversations
with your dad you know right
so for me and that's just not really the
way that i think but i had this like
deeply rooted
feeling of like
um
i mean maybe it's even attachment
to our friendship you know so it's like
i'm sure it wasn't my idea to go to
summer camp back when we did that years
earlier but i was like well if if red's
gonna go i'll go
i still may hate it and be the one that
means we're not gonna go again
but
you know we're hatching these ideas like
okay we can make
we make videos for presentations we
are funny weary we're a duo
like that was our biggest identity in
high school above these other things
we're talking about so for me
without knowing the application of it i
was just like
this is
i'm comfortable in this friendship i
have
um
i have hopes i i don't know that i had
my own dreams i had my own hopes so i
kind of felt like when you brought the
dream
and attached it to it's like my hope
immediately paid off
so it was like this huge relief i felt
like
as much as you practice basketball with
your special shoes and your blocks and
like like we couldn't we couldn't go and
uh swim in the river until you had done
it you had shot 100 basketball shots
maybe 300. like three like i would go
over to your house and just sit in your
yard and just be like what the hell man
yeah it's like hurry up dude it was just
like
i was just waiting on you to get done so
we could go
chase cows so
that that dynamic was at play on the
macro scale too of like
who am i to say
hey yeah let's
let's hatch a plan to be filmmakers
you know i felt like i was at the
mercy of like this basketball plan
so when you start saying things like
we can do this i can do we can do i can
do both so that we can do this
and if i because that's what i really
want to do we need to do something it's
like
you know making a blood oath for me
was such a validation
of my hope so it's like oh this is this
is official rhett actually prioritizes
what we can do together
over this basketball thing because
it you know
leading up to that for years it wasn't
like
we didn't have those type of
conversations about everything you know
it wasn't
i'm sure there were many times where
there were like question marks it was
like well i'm not going to push this i'm
also not one to like
have specific futuristic dreams
so
once once you made it official with the
oath and then once you start making
these plans i'm like yes yes yes
it was like a relief to me
because it's just something that i was
hoping that would come together but i
couldn't push
um
and then when it when you come back and
you're like it's it's you know once you
realize that's not gonna happen
you know and the reason that in the and
you know what happened
we got very serious about the band that
summer uh that was after junior year
yeah so that was when you know towards
the second half of junior year and the
summer before senior year is when
it kind of in that time frame
is when
our music went from singing like
country covers to lead singers with
cowboy hats and white t-shirts and jeans
to like i i'm gonna actually i'm gonna
get a guitar i'm gonna learn how to get
to get uh play guitar and write music
because because i feel like we need to
take this in a certain direction we
don't need to be like playing other
people's songs we need to be writing our
own music
yeah and
um
i mean i always i tell i tell that story
like i was embarrassed that we had two
lead singers and so i started playing
guitar
that's the joke version the real version
is is i was like hey we need to write
our own music
you know this if we're going to be a
band we need to be defining some kind of
style or something and it doesn't need
to be the eagles
right and so which is what benny had
written in the 70s and again i am uh i
am if i'm really good at anything it's
drinking my own kool-aid right it's like
i am great at making and drinking my own
kool-aid
that's kind of what propels me i think i
i think i like it too apparently my my
gasoline is the is my kool-aid and so
once we start writing music
by the time basketball season rolls
around
i specifically remember thinking
okay i'm gonna do this because i you
know i have gotten to this point and
i've done all this work for basketball
and so i'm gonna try you know to some
extent but i'm not going to play college
basketball like i had made a decision
before i even started playing my senior
year that i wasn't going to play college
basketball i wasn't telling my dad that
but i was kind of like i'm going to do
well and i'm going to shoot a hell of a
lot of threes but
my future is as a rock musician
you know what i'm saying like that's
what i was thinking that yeah we were
both
so aligned we were both so committed to
the band
that
it was and it was much more real right
then than being filmmakers
right so and it wasn't like it eclipsed
we'll never make videos again but it was
like right now the the thing we're
trying to break into is this music
industry and specifically the christian
music industry at the time in a very
particular time in place
um
so that's why that dream went away so
i'm actually interested to see what i
don't know well if this has anything to
say
your book has anything to do with that
yeah like
the thing that i've found here is
the
senior
appreciation what's it called like your
last words is your senior quote senior
quote that's what it's called
now i would i i'm not gonna i'm gonna
guess that
what i would say in this situation and
what you would say in this situation
wasn't actually true what was more about
what are people going to think when they
read this and are they going to laugh
are they going to think that we're weird
or it was more about what how people
would perceive it that's how i would
have approached this so that's what i'm
yeah guessing this is a public statement
so it has to be this is not a personal
personal mission statement
i rep mclaughlin
leave at the speed of a plunge from the
75-foot plunge cliff
with a pod at my side
get em dogs with a z so do you want to
um
uh let me read mine and then you can
just we can decipher both of them
uh let's see i link neil
leave with the boys pondering the pod
acapulco
wax paper dogs and various excursions we
mentioned all exactly the same things
knowing harnett central high school will
catastrophically crumble in our
absence
catastrophically crumble in our absence
so which by the way that phrase
uh
knowing that it will catastrophically
crumble in our absence is totally
something that my son would write in his
yearbook like just like this fake
bravado that he just i don't know that's
his sense of humor
which son lincoln um not lando the uh so
lake acapulco
was
a lake in lillington that was an old
rock quarry that had been
where we would you would break in and
you would jump the fence and you would
jump off of the cliff which was actually
probably 35 feet it was very tall but it
wasn't 75 it's taller from the top it
wasn't 75 feet but it's probably 35 feet
it was it was enough to if you didn't
land right you get hurt so that's what
you called the plunge cliff and i called
acapulco yeah yeah because by senior
year that was the thing that we were
we were instigating groups going jumping
the fence and it would hopefully
there'll be a full moon so you could see
but i mean it was scary jumping off of
this cliff
um because the it was a it was a
swimming hole a lot of a lot of
military people would come up from fort
bragg and swim there and get drunk and
some of them would jump off and a few
people died yeah
so they closed it down and it was it was
never open day or night
it was abandoned i would love to go by
there i know it's so close to my my
nana's house
um
but yeah jumping off of that cliff in
the dark was petrifying and if you hit
wrong you could really get hurt and we
we talked to all of our friends to jump
like boys and girls
to jump off of that thing
it was terrifying
so it became this rite of passage and of
course we were the instigators
and then
everybody did it because we made them do
it well there's a peer pressure you know
yeah that's everyone gets a really hard
time if they don't do it yeah it wasn't
just us but it was our idea so yeah we
i mean i guess senior year that was like
the that was like the big thing that we
were getting people to do so you were
leaving at the speed of a plunge off of
the lake acapulco cliff with the pod at
my side so that was the camping pod that
was the group of guys and occasionally
girls who would
camp by the river
we were very proud of that group right
we started letting them come out and
chase the cows with us at night and camp
with us it wouldn't just be the two of
us but it'd be a group of us that was
fun i mean the fact that we didn't go
out there and drink
i think most people probably expected
that that was what was they expected it
but no we're gonna like
we might drink some coke that's not what
we do yeah if it was
if some if some of our other friends
were in charge
then they would have
then we'd have been drinking and i'll
tell you that would have been fun
it could have been really dangerous
though yeah especially crossing the
river so i'm glad i mean i'm glad we
didn't for our own safety but like yeah
because we were in charge we got to set
the rules and it was it and we were very
pious because again the third piece of
this when you're like get em dogs
it's like the wax paper dogs was like
the biggest thing on our mind it wasn't
like you're gonna see my film we didn't
put that neither one of us put that and
we put the same thing like we had really
we really developed our group of guy
friends and then our group of guy and
girlfriends so the message i wrote to
you is not compelling here no actually i
don't there's not one
well you did not write in my senior year
book how is that possible
i don't know man i don't know maybe it
was just too pure
yeah you didn't you didn't write it i'll
look again i mean
surely i did somewhere
my
my girlfriend whoa just tiny fun she
well she wrote a lot yeah
um i learned from this that we had only
we've been dating for three months
at the like that when i graduated
that's really late to start a
relationship yeah like you should have
thought twice about that i didn't uh
you know so that's what i mean that's
why it was like it lasted through
freshman year because it had just
started senior year like i came back and
went to prom with her
oh you did that yes well college boycott
because she was a she was she because
she was a junior yeah like when i was a
senior she was a sophomore so like
so yeah that was a bit more acceptable
at the time
just to throw that out there we're all
very old
um
and here's
my good friend
who was my girlfriend and then my why
did she say enemy she was she was
leaving a room for somebody else to
write something i guess maybe no you
didn't you go to the front you did not
write in my yearbook i wrote the front
no no no you didn't
that's it this is sad
you'll have to see if i wrote in yours
dude but but yeah so
it's not that big of a deal
well i mean i guess it can't be because
that didn't happen maybe i'll maybe i'll
write in it now
but we you know we had we had this group
of friends
first of all talk about the prom you
know we have that iconic prom photo
in my girlfriend's front yard where
we're shaking hands and we got the one
leg lifted in the air well i found these
photos i took before
uh we went to my girlfriend's house my
mom took pictures of just me and you in
my kitchen
and boy where i mean
we're doing the pointy fingers
oh we're going to the prom
but not together we do have dates
working your tails oh it's me you in the
fridge
me and you
thinking about how much fun the prom is
gonna be
this is just us getting ready for meet
and greets in the future we have to come
up with different ways to pose and here
we here we are shaking hands but we did
not lift the leg this is the precursor
to the leg lift
and then there we are just kind of
styling and wide shot total side note
here
when i started looking back through
these photos
i was like oh man
i remember my kitchen
you know it's like the photo my mama's
taking a photo of us but i'm just
looking around that kitchen
it's like you never just take photos of
your childhood kitchen
thinking when you're a middle-aged man
you it will trigger so many memories
but like look at i remember that i still
haven't done the thing that you know i
talked about this a couple years ago
taking that 360 degree camera i know we
need to take pictures of the inside of
the house so my kids will always
remember what their rooms would look
like but i gotta do that before a lot
goes off to college but if you look at
this is when we were at the graduation
party at the maranatha cafe and you just
look at all these all of our friends and
like
you know
a lot a couple of them were dating
i dated you know some of us had dated
each other and then broke up and still
stayed friends and like you know i miss
these people man
the last time we had a reunion i wasn't
able to go because it was a hurricane
yep and
it's like you know you go back home and
like we we really had a special friend
group
where it was like
um
some of them put up with our piety all
of them put up with our craziness and
they were a lot of them were along for
the ride with our crazy ideas like we're
going to cross this river with
everything we got in trash bags and if
you get swept down the river
we'll come get you just just go to that
bank not back where you came because
then you'll have to cross again like
that was the instructions and keep your
feet in front of you so you don't die
they were petrified
they were getting them jumping off
cliffs but like going over there and
camping and
you know it's like you're just staring
at this photo like is it are the
memories flooding back or something i'm
just looking at everybody
i mean and to think about
we are younger
than lily is now we're younger than
lakas now
and i just think
this is almost the exact i mean this
same age is the same age as like yeah
and almost the same age as lincoln right
now and i just think
i remember thinking about how much
i had figured out
you know
really i just thought we were like
i thought i was a fully functional human
i was not
well yeah i mean
it's just the least yeah um
yeah i don't know i don't know exactly
what i'm doing what i'm thinking because
you know i yeah i'm very
i'm you know in trying to relate this to
the to the dynamic of our of our
friendship it was such an interesting
thing because we were so we felt like
there was and there was there was
something special between the two of us
that sort of
um
eclipsed anything any other connection
we had with other people
and that had been so that had begun to
solidify because of the dynamic that i
talked about earlier about just kind of
being on the same team
conceptually in the way that we wanted
to approach life and deal with things
and then
for whatever reason
can we explore this in a different
episode
but we got so serious about our faith
and everything became about
the great commission
you know it's like the our lives are
going to be about the great commission
yeah we're going to be in a band
but that is superseded by
this idea that we're that we're doing it
all for the glory of god
um and because
none of the other guys in the group were
like okay i'm gonna go along with that
uh i mean of course the guys in the band
did but they were like in different
grades and you know it was it was they
were we knew we were friends with them
through the band we just had this like
double whammy
connection because there was a
conceptual sort of stylistic connection
yeah but then there was the world view
connection
so
wrapping up high school and getting
ready to go into college there was just
this and again this wasn't anything we
processed you can only kind of see this
looking back
there was
a very unusual
connection
that we were then taking into college
because we were also oh we're gonna go
to college and room together and study
is you know the same thing essentially
yeah getting uh we're gonna get
it to me
there's this thing with twins right
and you've got different types of twins
but you've got the twins who get to the
end of their high school and they begin
making decisions about college and
they're like well of course we're going
to go to the same school and we're going
to have the same and we knew twins like
that we knew twins that you kind of
experienced in college
um
[Music]
but you but in twins eventually they
make sometimes they make a choice
sometimes they don't i mean there's a
thanks to the internet i know about a
set of twins that married a set of twins
and they all live together
it happens interesting possibilities
there but but even for twins it was that
was a point that's a point where you it
could be a point of separation that was
never on the table for us it was like
basically
i was gonna go to college wherever
you're gonna go to college
if if basketball was a determining
factor
right and then when it just became about
um well you're good at math and you're
good at science so you should you should
go into engineering and that's true of
both of us
and
michael jubie's parents took us to visit
states campus and we were we were close
with michael yep and trent was going to
nc state michael was going to nc state
so it was like and they were they were
part of our pod
um
don he was going to nc state
um
nobody else from our friend group was
going to nc state but most of the dudes
that's for you
five of us
yeah
so i'm actually surprised ecu
uh i think he thought he was going to
stay and then maybe he switched up
i think that's what happened because he
wrote a note in my yearbook about going
to state together but i'm actually
surprised that we didn't stay closer
with uh trent and michael but they were
on the other side of campus and of
course we're not going to get into
college uh if we keep this series going
and maybe we should you know we always
think we've told all these stories but
like looking at it through the lens of
our friendship i think it is
there's a different dynamic there so
it's like we were bringing that
like this twin energy
i guess to
to follow your logic here into our our
college career
and um
but
yeah looking back on high school
it was
i mean we had the we had all these
different ways that we were
that i mean we didn't even talk about
the church aspect of it but
yeah that that's kind of what the band
grew out of so there's so many different
like identity defining
elements of our high school career that
then
we're we're all real pretty rewarding
and our french friendship group was uh
was also a big part of that i just i
think that's my takeaway is that like
uh feeling a little sappy about the
friend the friends we had back then and
uh good time you know and
and whenever
the no not everybody has that when when
i read the notes it's like
um to me it's like man you were you were
so crazy thanks for thanks for bringing
so much to our friend group and to our
friendship we weren't we weren't always
on the best terms but we they we always
came back together as as friends i still
love you like a lot all the girls at
some point there must have been a thing
because most of them ended up saying to
me you had a way of crossing all of them
but i still love you you know yeah well
that's not surprising so
i'm sure in in
in their own way all mythical team
members can feel the same way even now
yeah exactly yes stevie she's like oh
yeah link but i still love him i think
it's a lot of people feel you got to dig
up your yearbooks man don't stand on the
top i'll find them i have to get i need
to get a robot to help me so do you have
a wreck oh yeah let's get to the wreck
uh
tick-tock i recommend following
this is ranger keith
have you seen this guy
no he he goes out into the woods and
it's almost meditative
and he's like
hey
get out of your head
are you doing your best
[Music]
that's not the one i want to show you
hey
it's ranger keith i'm out burning this
morning and i thought you might want to
take a minute to just wind down a little
bit we're just going to sit and listen
be present if you don't know your bird
calls that's okay i'll just tell you
what they are as we go
oh there was a
blue gray in that catcher
cheeseburger cheeseburger cheeseburger
down the hill it's a carolina rim
carolina red
again
[Music]
all right
i'll see you later
there you go i'm mesmerized this is
ranger keith is he in north carolina i
love you man i don't know where he is
he's with birds well i mean i guess the
carolina wren can uh migrate elsewhere
i love a tough tit mouse not tit mouse
whatever it is i don't know
wow he's a very peaceful man yeah that's
what you get on tick tock if you want it
anything you want yes it's not it's not
dancing i mean it is dancing teenagers
but none of those come up in my for you
page so hashtag your biscuits thanks for
um
experiencing our friendship with us
again
yes
to watch more ear biscuits click on the
playlist on the right to watch the
previous episode of your biscuits click
on the playlist to the left and don't
forget to click on the circular icon to
subscribe if you prefer to listen to
this podcast it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms thanks for
being your mythical best
[Music]